meghan mccain is back on the view and
she's sharing the first pics of
three-month-old daughter
liberty sage being with a newborn baby
has been it's been surprising to me
because motherhood i think as everyone
knows was not a
simple journey for me baby liberty is
megan's first child
she and husband ben welcomed her on
september 28
2020. being with her is like the way
i've heard described taking ecstasy
it's just amazing and it's like i've
been in this bubble of love and
baby time and she's just perfect on
instagram megan captioned the three
shots quote someone wanted to see me on
monday's episode of the view the 36 year
old also said having baby liberty
felt like quote having a little piece of
my dad back
of course megan's dad is late arizona
senator john mccain
who died in 2018 at the age of 81 after
battling cancer
the proud mama also used her return from
maternity leave to discuss the hardships
of her pregnancy
when i gave birth i actually had
postnatal preeclampsia and i was in the
hospital for a week after on a magnesium
drip and it really
really kicked my butt and i was planning
on coming back to the show for the
election
and six weeks after i gave birth and i
was physically unable to i was
physically unable to come i was having
as any woman who has experienced
anything like that i had to have my
husband and my mother-in-law help me do
everything from shower to eat it was
deeply humbling and to help me take care
of liberty
it was during this candid discussion
that she stressed the importance of paid
maternity leave for all women
the whole time i was thinking what a
privilege it is to have this kind
of maternity leave and then as i thought
about it
the more angry i got that there weren't
women
in the rest of america that had the same
kind of luxury that i had
working here at the view and she didn't
stop
there if we're going to continue growing
as a country and we're going to be able
to give
you know women and families the capacity
to grow in the way that we want and stop
having this sort of like
you know societal fracture that we're
having and a lot of arguments are made
it's because
of the fracture that's happening at home
and with families we as conservatives
have to come together
and allow all women in this country no
matter where they're from or
their socio-economic class the capacity
to have what i just had which is three
months of bonding time and breastfeeding
and healing from an emergency c-section
megan has always been passionate about
speaking out on issues
close to her heart i mean sometimes i'm
calm sometimes i'm not i mean people
that watch the show know that
um i try and just remind myself that i'm
representing 50
of the country i'm representing a bunch
of women even though i only have one
[Music]
chair